uno tra i più bei giochi free to play al
mondo a un nuovo in già in grafico e
recentemente è stato ricostruito è
rifatto quindi è completamente diverso
da quello che era una volta molto
parlare un conto giocare un altro quindi
devo far vedere che so fare i mazzi
facciamo vedere questi 4 mila gli
iscritti valgono qualcosa da grazie di
ragazzi e benvenuti questo video sono
falli jazz un su world of tanks nel caso
vi stesse chiedendo come faccio ad avere
tutta questa roba perché sono
raccomandato me l'hanno data possiamo
partire i ragazzi andiamo in battaglia
casuale la cosa che volevo dirvi è che è
chiara la dinamica di gioco se non
conoscete world of tanks da ci sono i
carri armati grossi io sono vuote hobbs
una squadra contro l'altra da una parte
abbiamo il miglior giocatore del mondo
dall'altra matilda siate buoni con me
perché nei giochi di guerra io sono
bravo con fino a un certo punto ho già
porca vacca nuovo visto i cespugli che
si mi scusi albero sicuramente questi ci
sono gli saranno in grado di non mi
stanno riparando come pensavo porca
vacca che male che male della vita
proprio ma non lo becco mai ma che era
un attimo allora meno male almeno il mio
team ha vinto la battaglia
no no nel senso va beh siamo un po di
soddisfazione anche i nemici giustamente
io volevo chiamarmi carro armando però
non me l'hanno fatto fare mi sarei
chiamato così comunque per vostra
informazione 2 su mi dicono che è grosso
sappiamo tutti che le dimensioni contano
chi è che ce la più lunga la canna vado
con gli altri perché l'ultima volta sono
andato da solo me la sono presa in
ciapet quindi evitiamo eccolo lì lo zio
urca vacca danno causato di elevato 300
quanto le vostro cane armato occhio lo
faccio fuori laga è mio
raga celti 10 che è rimasto a 800 di
vita però non lo farò mai fuori perché
se mi avvicino un implodono lo sapete
che vi dico
iolo bardolino stesse a corto di messa e
non penso di sì prove
mi sa che non se n'era accorto occhio
che si gira e se si gira a me la prendo
intercooler ciao amico
no l'ho mancato bicicletta questa è uno
scontro veramente brutto che male
c'è una cosa che vedo cosa succede ai a
chiamare si ok basta stato beh magari
devo levarmi l'acqua vendite è stato
bello avere la perché poi io ve lo
spiego allora siccome ho un account gold
per niente sono livello altissimo io
però ho giocato poco a world of tanks è
veramente fatto poche partite mi sta
mettendo contro la gente più forte che
esista non è una partita contro quelli
che hanno iniziato a giocare da poco
tipo me è rappresentato quelli forti
forti forti per me aver fatto una kill è
tanto capita e proprio tanto detto
questo la partita la perderemo perché la
nostra squadra fa schifo veneti occhio
davanti a noi c'è una rissa che si è
incazzato provare a brava mi difendimi
fi tunnel il lavoro sporco io prendo i
meriti e quello lì in teoria se
riuscisse a infilarmi in mezzo
mamma mia che male è rimasto 200
attenzione via via via via via fuori le
palle
amico mio dammi la mano da infami
marcate il tutto ha detto abete ha detto
sento zio e siamo in una morsa rho scala
che arriva l'altro allora facciamo una
cosa bella
tu gioca io vado via del male nel mondo
dell'ambiente
amico mio dobbiamo farlo fuori insieme
sono sei morti c'è un altro che sta
arrivando fortissimo peccato perché
eravamo messi bene attenzione questa
arrivate in carica fortissimo arrivo è
arrivo fratelli esistere un secondo
l'altro andato quello conferito prima
vai vai colpiscilo dai 22 i due sbagli
vai fa niente è stato bello
arrivederci marca vacca che male c'è se
ne passo io vivo insieme ad un altro
quindi abbiamo perso praticamente questo
ci prova ci prova ci prova e io devo
ricaricare ancora il colpo no l'ho
mancato uccidetemi muoio dada vittorioso
muoio da dignitoso e vittorioso perché
gli open e feriti un sacco non fatto
fuori uno o ferito pure te penso di
deficiente sono orgoglioso di questa
partita ho perso ma sono veramente ci
siamo ragazzi tutti la battaglia con
questo mega tank proviamo a vedere se
riesco a fare un qualcosa di decente
come prima mi piace questo anche perché
abbastanza bilanciato l'unico problema è
successo ma pensavo avessero passato gli
oggetti alla cassa spunta da lì ed n
che male forte chi stato beh io seguo i
miei compagni
mamma mia povera macchina ma qua ci
facciamo fuori i muri come se fossero
carta igienica quelle dietro un muro ma
non ha capito che il muro è fatto di
carta quindi quindi
mi casa troppo quando faccio fare un
carro armato regale cioè scusate la
nostra squadra sta per essere implosa
però io ho fatto una kill sono morti
solo in due degli altri una kill è mia
ma ci sono due carri armati cavalca non
l'ho visto mai nulla l'ho visto che
aiuta mio amico studio 1 arcavacata raga
mi dovete aiutare sono morto se no sai
quello che esce da lì no no no è morto
il mio amico lì non ho visto è stavolta
niente
stavolta niente però io ci riprovo
perché non si demorde uccido vi faccio
rimpiangere di essere ma che il giorno
vi faccio rimpiangere di essere no jolo
mamma mia che brutta roba fatto che è
pronta scherzavo ciao salve non volevo
fare questo però va bè ayachi male
porca vacca non muore niente
vabbè porca vacca come siamo partiti
forte qua regala una gara di formula 1
che arrivo io a darti supporto zio lo so
che sei in difficoltà faccio io ho la
corazza non è stata perforata mi hanno
fatto malissimo me ne vado a casa
quello lì e mezzo di struttura è un
bersaglio facilissimo io veramente ho
peccato non fermino peccato io però è
morto quando gli ho sparato io come
possibile ok raga questa stiamo vincendo
le mancano solo sei e gli altri abbiamo
vinto eccolo lì forum
a occhio che mi vecchia perfetto ragazzi
gioco di squadra così funziona quello
ragione è l'ultimo abbiamo finito quel
piccolo sputato addosso è morto per
farlo bene grazie
un partita bing visto sgasando in faccia
ma non è colpa mia giuro credo che non
ci sia null'altro da aggiungere
ho fatto tutto io quindi ragazzi dire
che possiamo concludere qui oggi con
world of tanks comunque ragazzi se non
ci avete mai giocatrici giocate in
questi giorni in questi giorni ci sono
delle i bonus tipo per i nuovi giocatori
che siano solo con un codice che vi
lascio con descrizione scaricatelo
perché una bomba da bob gioco di guerra
migliori youtuber italia coi ragazzi io
comunque ho bisogno su world of tanks mi
sono fatto vedere chi è che pensa al
contrario un buffo come al solito
servito il piaciuto sul punto è un mi
piace anche a rischio cioè che come da
prescrizioni se avresti si chiede e noi
ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]